even as nevada continues to reopen
thousands of people across the state are
still out of a job that includes workers
on the las vegas strip
but a new bill at the state legislature
could help
orco mana joins us live on the strip
tonight to explain exactly how
orca well brian as more lights come back
on here on the las vegas strip
laid off hospitality workers are itching
to get back to work
the right to return bill would guarantee
them that chance
but not everyone thinks it's the best
path forward
we don't have jobs we don't have
anything for two decades norma flores
worked as a server at a local resort she
was laid off one year ago as covet 19
concerns shut down las vegas
now it's tough to make ends meet with a
pandemic
no more tips nothing and it's hard with
the unemployment
their take time to give it to me as
nevada reopens flores wants to get back
to work and she hopes senate bill 386
can help the right to return bill would
make casinos hotels and tourism related
industries offer laid off workers their
former jobs or similar positions
before considering other options but
some do not agree with the legislation
it's inappropriate republican state
senator keith pickard says
employees could falsely accuse resorts
of not offering them jobs
we're opening the door to litigation and
it makes it
very difficult for an employer to prove
they didn't do this
democratic senate majority leader nicole
cannizzaro who introduced the bill
acknowledges companies need protections
and she's working on that
for bad actors who want to take
advantage of that process we obviously
want to make sure there's some
enforcement mechanisms
some casino companies opposed the bill
saying it would result
in restrictive requirements but the
culinary union has a message for
employers
they have to realize the best thing for
this community to moving forward is give
it to the right person to go back
flores hopes everyone will get on board
we deserve
to come back to work
nevada lawmakers are working through the
details of the bill right now
next on the agenda is likely another
committee hearing
reporting live on the las vegas strip
tonight orco mana 8 news now